Having given you the abstractions and PTS, and the simplicity of the programming
model. I will now introduce you to the heavy lifting that needs to happen
under the covers in order to support
this simple programming model from the point
of view of the domain expert developing
a situation awareness application. All the computations
in the application can be considered as
either producers or consumers of data. Producers
of data, are putting things into the
system and consumers of data are getting stuff
from the system. And under the covers there are worker threads in the run-time
system of PTS that react to these
get calls coming from the producers and consumers.
For instance, whenever, a producer puts an item, that results in
new item triggers. That are going to be generated by the worker threads to the
rest of the implementation. Implementation of
the channel architecture is a three
layer architecture. The top layer is the live channel layer of the architecture.
And this is the layer that reacts to
the new item triggers coming from these worker
threads, working on behalf of a put call that is coming from a producer. So the
channel abstractions result in these new item triggers
to be sent to the live channel layer.
Of the channel architecture. And the live channel
layer, is the one that is holding a snapshot
of items that have been generated on
a particular channel. Starting from the oldest item
in the channel to the newest item that just came in because of this new item
trigger At the time of creation of a channel, the creator of a channel could
specify what the semantics of the data that
are kept in this channel are. In particular,
a creator of a channel could say that, what I want the channel to contain are
live data corresponding to a certain snapshot of
real time. From oldest to new. For instance,
I could say keep only the last 30 seconds of data in the channel. Rest of
it, you can throw it away. So there is a garbage collection trigger that is part
of the run time system, that is looking
at information that is in the channel, that says.
What items in the channel have become old
and therefore can be thrown away. Those are the
Gc triggers. And the Gc triggers will move
data that have become ancient, so far as this
channel is concerned, and move it into this
garbage list. Meaning that these items are no longer
relevant from the point of view of this
application. And therefore they can be garbage collected.
So they're put into this garbage list. And
there is another garbage collection thread that is responsible
for periodically cleaning up all the garbage that
has been created and throwing away stuff that
is no longer relevant. For this computation. So
this is all the channel book keeping that's happening,
under the covers in support of an application that is using the PTS library.
But there's a lot more to it than just dealing with live data and data that
is no longer relevant that has to be garbage collected or thrown away. As I
mentioned one of the features of the
PTS architecture is the fact that an application
can choose to keep data for as long as they wants, and that is the
persistence property supported by PTS run time system.
So once again properties of the channel An
application programmer could specify that, I don't
want to throw away stuff that becomes old
to keep in the channel, but I want to archive them, I want to persist them.
And if those properties have been associated
with the channel, then when items go past
the window that has to be stored in
the Live Channel Layer. The Live Channel Layer
results in generating what are called persistent
triggers to indicate that some items have become
old in this channel, and they have to
be persisted. The second main functional layer in
the channel architecture is the Persistence layer.
The Interaction layer is just a go between
the Live Channel layer and the Persistence
layer of the channel architecture. And what the
Persistence layer does is, based on the
persistence triggers that it gets from the live
channel layer. It is going to take items from
the channel and decide how to persist them.
Now, here again, the application can have a say in how items need to
be persisted. And they do that by
having a Pickling Handler. That is, the application
can specify Here is a function that I want you to use every time you decide
to persist some item from the channel. For example, an application may specify
that don't store all the images as is on archive or storage,
but Condense them in such and so fashion. And that is a function that it can
supply. And the runtime system, when it
works on persistence, will automatically apply the
application-specified function on the items that need
to be persisted to create a digest.
Which will then be persistent. Items that need to be persistent necessarily have
to go to non-volatile storage devices, and
here again, the PTS architecture supports several
different configured Backends to store items that
need to be persistent. And the Backend
layer is the third layer in the
channel architecture. And PTS supports several different
Backends to support the persistence activities and
it is an application choice as to
which back end layer it wants to use for its specific application. The Backend
layers supported by PTS include mySQL, it can use Unix file system as a
persistence layer, or it can use a file system from IBM called GPFS. So mySQL,
Unix file system, and GPFS are the three different Backends that are available.
For the persistence layer to store channel data that needs to be archived for
later retrieval. The nice property is that all of the persistence activities
happen unbeknownst to the user. All that the user has done is in the creation of
a channel. Specified certain properties to associate
with that channel. For example, the property that
may have been associated with a channel is that any items beyond the last 30
seconds persistent on the storage, and when
you persist them on the storage, apply this
function. Those are the things being specified
by the user creation time of the channel,
once that is done the heavy lifting that needs to be done during down time,
is all handled under the covers, by
the run time system. Of the channel architecture
that takes items from the channel, pickles
them using the function that has been specified,
and uses one of the configured Backends to
push those pickled items onto the persistent storage.
On the other side, when. An application wants to get an item. That item range
may span from something that is there in the live channel part of the three
layer architecture, or it could be on the archival storage. Now it is up to the
run time system to retrieve all the items between the lower bond. And the upper
bound specified by get primitive. So get primitive that spans both live and
archived items results in get triggers being
passed from the light channel through the
interaction layer to the Backend so that corresponding to the get interval that
is specified. The Backend layer can pull the data from the archive storage and
pass it up so that it finally gets
to the application. What I wanted to illustrate through
this picture is there is a lot of heavy
lifting that needs to happen in order to support
a simple programming model. The programming model is very
simple But, in order to support the simplicity, all
of the heavy lifting has to be absorbed under
the covers in the run time system of the
PTS programing model.